tes parents il dit quoi plus les gens
choqués bien sûr ils ont peur pour toi
ben en fait qu'ils ont pas plus que peur
en lisant j'ai l'impression que c'est
eux qu'est qui ont vécu la chose à ma
place c'est normal si les airs a nice on
ne sait pas comment quand vous dire face
ce soir mais
sans trace en avait une soutiennent ils
soutiennent vraiment je le remercie
mais même en fait j'ai l'impression que
il fait pas avec moi ces jours là j'ai
l'impression
alors vous avez confié que ce n'était
pas la première fois vous subissiez
jurant de violence depuis le collège
vous subissez des faits de harcèlement
et de violence qu'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis quand vous faites agresser un
depuis ma cm là tu as dix et on vous
souhaite en tentant quelques classes
moyennes déjà régis u2 cole arrivé
d'accord
ça a joué sa dont le fait que tu te sois
déscolarisés tu n'es plus à l'école
qu'est ce qui se passe à dix mois
l'école ben je me faisait harceler
des fois sexuellement
des fois
sexuellement c'est à dire pas de par
d'autres élèves oui il faut que les
élèves du collège auquel cas son 6e ça
c'est la première fois d'abus sexuels
moi ça se passe en sixième ce qui s'est
passé il ya un jeune homme qui venait
derrière devant tout le monde en tout la
cour mcdc pantalon je sais que tous les
droits tout le monde j'ai tout de suite
comme ça plus son choc et ont porté
plainte
la personne n'a pas été viré
d'établissement
et voilà ça c'est la première agression
c'est ça ensuite paris qui s'est passé
il faut que tu as été séquestrée dans
ton collège c'est ça non ça c'était dans
mon lit c'était trop longtemps lycée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là
chante la cantine parler me laver les
mains d'accord ça des jeunes de mon
essai sans vie vous frappez du comment
j'ai couru je me suis caché dans des
toilettes ils sont donc venus avec des
tournevis ont frappé des tournevis ils
ont ouvert la porte et le tour nos vies
nous frapper je devais finir à 17 heures
ce jour-là j sortir à 14 heures gj je me
sens fier gêné ces jeux sortis tout
c'est un des porte plainte au
commissariat de montgeron d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qui est des professeurs et on
dit quoi
rien oui ce que tu as porté plainte
qu'en inde et par son vétéran de la
plainte et je vais porter plainte car
tourné dans 6 6 après je suis retourné
deux ou trois mois après
et voilà près jamais après un séjour b
plus tard ils m'ont dit que je devais
redoublé parce que j'avais trop
d'absences et du coup j'ai dit excusez
moi mais moi je reviens plus ici je suis
désolé au revoir leur jeu mais quand
vous portez plainte vous y allez avec
vos parents ou une enquête fait ça en
fait s'est classée sans suite d'accord
voilà
enfin attendent de speed pourtant j'ai
des prénoms on a tout mais on m'a jamais
rappelée pour mieux réussir ici
on hamel en fait tous cet acharnement
faut partir du point de départ et alice
il était beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux d'accord il faisait beaucoup de
vidéos de snapshot où il faisait des
playbacks où il danse et ouvrait des des
petites manier du coup les gens se sont
déjà il est gay et alors mais calibre
incident voilà le suisse est parti de sa
et à 30 mois tous les jours tous les
jours que jalousie des insultes des
menaces à regarde ton frère y fait quoi
ah mais vous n'avez pas honte et où
c'est dur pour nous on est sa famille
c'est pas comme si on était des des
inconnus ou le voisin quand ça nous
touche nous personnellement ça fait mal
ça fait très très mal c'est pour ça que
tout cet acharnement de base elle a
commencé parce qu'ils s'amusaient sur
les réseaux sociaux etc delà de bouche à
oreille des premières vidéos il se
faisait agresser dans notre quartier se
faisait frapper aussi du coup ma mère
pour le protéger est le sort du quartier
c'était encore pire c'est c'était
vraiment pire et eux ils ont dû le
reconnaître par rapport à ses anciennes
vidéos qui faisait sur snap et tout
parce que pour dire ah le guet le pb est
tout
on peut pas y qu'est ce qui paraît alors
comme tu m'as dit il ya eu plusieurs
agressions dans le cadre scolaire
personne n'a agi personnes personne
pourtant laissé en détresse enfin
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec une
altercation avec ton prof en 4e et
4e l'image est un sport dans la premier
de j il ya une jeune fille ham avait
baissé mon pantalon
jusqu'aux
ici
et je suis parti dans le projet t elle
va baisser mon pantalon il m'a dit à
quoi elle a baissé son pantalon il dit
mais si jamais vous dira baisse mon
pantalon vous comprenez pas dans quoi
elle baisse mon pantalon et il m'a dit
un jour tu m'as dit vaches et la cpg
parti chasser pêcher il expliqué
du coup plus tard c'est moi qui a été
viré pour ce collège parce que j'ai mal
parlé à mon professeur
en sachant qu'il savait très bien que je
subissais de l'harcèlement radiation des
cépages ça vraiment lâche que virer une
victime
ça parce que je me suis navré je suis
humain comme nous tous ici ce soir
chacun ses faiblesses vacances et
profond tiens moi j'étais seul je
savais pas comment réagir du coup et je
vais dire au professeur tu viens en
enfer depuis depuis la classe de 6e c ça
en fait c'est à dire quand tu sors dans
la rue même dans ton quartier toujours
oui tu le sais toujours frappé nuit
enfin quand je sors mais maintenant
short ou non mais je marche avec nolan à
la collection l'agression tu savais fin
tu savais pas mais tu te disais ça va
arriver un jour aussi une agression
aussi violente puisque je me fais
toujours à gressier ovila peux tu vivais
là tu vis l'apéro c'est ça la peur au
jour le jour je marche avec ma mère un
jour avec ma soeur je me suis fait
insulter de bd devant ma mère devant une
barre de famille
il ya un discours maintes what a porté
plainte
qu est ce une dizaine de fois une
dizaine de fois et jamais on m'a rappelé